so hi I'm Joe Roberts I'm a product
manager here at posit who uh and I
managed the posit package manager
product appropriately enough and um one
of the biggest questions that I get
asked when in my role is uh particularly
from it administrators or info security
is how can I be sure that the public
packages that my data scientists want to
use are actually safe to use and it's a
very good question and one that we'll
dig into a bit today but I realize that
there's a lot of um just a lot of you
aren't it administrators a lot of data
scientists in the room who you already
know and love public packages so you
don't need to be convinced of this so
we're going to change the topic for you
for for you imagine this is how to
convince your infos team to let you use
the public packages that you
need and hopefully I'll give you some
tools here to actually have that
conversation when they come and say hey
you can't use these anymore because
they're security risk so um what I
wanted to go over today is just uh we'll
talk a bit about the public package
repositories because it's important to
understand how they work and how they
differ in order to have a good sense of
what the security risks are we'll then
talk about types those types of security
risks at least some of the more common
ones and then of course how to mitigate
those risks using tools like posit
package manager but also even if you're
not using package manager just some of
some tips and processes you can make you
can use with either your open source
tools or whatever you're using for
package management uh and we'll see how
that all works so first let's talk about
public package repositories the the big
ones that you're more likely to do with
is the data scientist um are of course
cray is the main r package repository if
you're in life scientists you've got you
got bioconductor with more packages of
for R and then on the python side you of
course have the python packages index or
pii so let's take a look at first I'll
talk about cran and bioconductor
together because at least as how they
approach public repositories they take a
very similar approach and if any of you
have ever tried to submit a package to
cray or bioconductor you know just how
difficult that can be sometimes uh and
for good reason so these are all you in
in order to submit a package you must it
has to pass a a lot of checks it has to
have good documentation at least
complete documentation for all the
functions in your package all of these
various things ultimately if you think
of it it's kind of like that exclusive
club with the bouncer at the door who's
basically saying no you cannot get in
here unless you you look the part um to
be sure I mean it it is they're not
curating your content they don't care if
you can dance but they do want to make
sure you look the part to go in the club
and so that's where you're going to go
there uh in the in the
alternatively the pii takes the opposite
approach to that it is your Wikipedia of
packages anyone can submit anything to
pii you can go on right now while we're
sitting in this talk create an account
on PPI and upload a python package that
will instantly become available to
pretty much the entire
world which has its advantages because
it does give a lot more Community
there's a far more greater number of
packages available on pii um but also in
that introduces of course some different
security risks that are kind of more
common there as well so we'll talk about
the is there let's jump into security
risks because that's the interesting
part um the I'm going to group this in
security risk this is one of the first
initial things that a lot of people care
about with packages is how do I um
assess package quality or really does
this package that I'm seeing on the
public repository do what it's supposed
to do and do it accurately and give me
the right results um and there are you
know it's it's it's a hard question to
ask because we didn't write the package
often we're trying to use packages that
we may not be domain experts in
ourselves that's why we're going to get
a package that someone else has written
to do it but there are some ways that we
can actually get a sense of this uh
things like look at the number of
downloads how off a more widely used
package is probably that way for a
reason because people trust it uh the
author reputation did hadly write the
package it may be okay compared to if
you know someone who just has one
package on the entirety of cran and then
they just and you don't really know who
they are what credentials they have
there to say those are bad but it's just
one factor we factor
in documentation good packages have good
documentation you know what it does you
can actually read and see what's going
on there uh a more interesting one is
revision history Ian if a package that
you see has frequent updates is up has
been updated recently can also give you
an indication that someone actually
cares about this and is working to fix
the bugs and maintain it as we go and of
course tests are always nice if they're
in there too because that can also give
you an indication that hey this there
are tests that show this is doing what
it's supposed to
do so how do we mitigate these I mean
ultimately there is no substitute in
package quality for a human review
someone actually has to take a look at
this and decide is this package good
enough to use often that that falls on
you as the individual data scientists
who's actually wanting to use this but
there are some more systematic ways of
doing it uh and there are assessment
tools to help with that our friends over
at the r validation Hub have created
this risk metric package for example for
r that does it essentially gathers a lot
of these metrics that you got from those
things we just talked about looking at
number of downloads and various other
attributes and a whole lot more that you
can then wait how you want to to decide
if a package is good sense anyway if the
package is worth actually using once you
have done that you can use tools like
posit package manager in your in your
organization to create a curated
repository that basically includes just
the packages that you or your
organization is just teed safe to use
and then your users can your data
scientists can just know that if it's in
this repository it's been vetted by our
organization or someone that we trust to
actually decide these things there so
that's what we kind of kind of a
bottomup approach to security where we
start with nothing and we just include
approved packages we want to
use most talks of security risks always
usually jump straight to vulnerabilities
which are what of course more
conventional security risks that want to
worry about um and when you're worried
about the nice thing about public
package repositories is that public
packages that have been published in one
of these repositories really is a known
quantity so you don't have to do
typically what what you typically would
do on a say a new development project or
something else where you need to do a
conventional scanning of it what really
is the case is that these public
packages are known quantities that have
been scanned by other people already I
mean people are already looking looking
at these so if there are issues often
those come up very quickly and are
reported in um so these could come up
these could be in s in the source code
they could be in compiled code they
could be in external libraries that
they're linking to and sometimes they're
malicious but often these
vulnerabilities just show up due to
poorly written code or just mistakes um
so when you have those and you see the
scanning of those you can actually look
at vulnerability databases that actually
I've already looked at these packages
and if you as long as you look and look
them up say this package this version in
these databases you can get a good sense
of are there any known vulnerabilities
um we here at posit have just started
working with our Consortium on a cray
and bioconductor advisory database um
that's you know there are relatively
again due to that the bouncer the door
of cranon bioconductor there aren't that
many vulnerabilities known out there but
there are a few that have come up on
usually in external packages they link
to um so we have that it's patterned
very closely after the much larger
python packaging environment of your
database that pii has and that's main
maintained by the python pack packaging
Advisory Group um both of those feed
into the open source vulnerabilities
database os. that Google started uh
which is a great place to actually go to
find it you know for any data science
package now at least in r in Python it's
a good place to start to look there and
once you have that you can leverage
features like in package manager called
package blocking where we would actually
uh you can actually say I want to take a
top- down approach to security where
instead of just approving the packages
we want to use we can start with we'll
we'll allow you to use anything in the
public repository but we're going to
block all of these versions of these
packages that have known vulnerabilities
in the database and continue to update
that as you um as new new
vulnerabilities come
out so those are two two kind of broad
areas of pack of uh security risks in
packages themselves we're going to jump
now over to some a couple of uh areas
that are more in the infrastructure used
to deliver packages which have seen
particularly on the python side some
real world exploits in the last year
plus so I group these as under package
confusion because they're they're really
all about trying to deceive the user
into installing the wrong package or not
the one that they actually are looking
for so two of those that we're going to
talk about today are typo squatting and
dependency
confusion typo squatting and so we have
a little example so we're we're going to
walk through our the life of a in
package installation here I'm going to
talk about these in terms of python and
pii and using pip to install them just
not to say that those aren't possible to
happen these aren't possible to happen
on the cray side and a bioconductor side
but again due to the curation it's much
less likely to happen there so and these
are all ripped from the headlines of
real world examples that have happened
in the python Community here so we have
our you're our we're a data scientist we
have an empty well starting with an
empty environment we have PPI we're
going to do some machine learning so
we're going to we want to get the tensor
flow package it's over a sitting in pii
great uh we do pip install tensor flow
and pip goes out oh I'm G to look up
tensor flow on PPI grab it over my local
machine everything's perfect that's what
we want to
happen now let's take it let's start
again here we've still got our pii but
now we're going to make a typo why do
you call it typo squatting well we have
a typo in I accidentally typed like we
all make mistakes once in a while two
ends in my tensor flow and I do pip
install tensor flow normally what would
happen pip goes out goes pii I want
tensor flow with two
n's Pipi goes I don't got one of those
and so pipp turns an error and actually
this is a good thing because this is
what you want to happen in those
situations you go back you see your typo
you move
on now let's get a little more nefarious
here so we're we're back with our PPI
here I then am a wearing my black hat my
a malicious python uh malicious hacker
trying to get into your system here I I
go and look at pii and I go hm what are
these packages that are very popular out
here oh tensorflow tensorflow to be to
be fair has 600,000 downloads a day from
pii and so I'm going to go out here
and as a user I'm coming with Pip
install tensor with two ends I'm going
to go out here as a malicious user and
I'm going to use that permissibility of
PPI to install a whole bunch of
different variants of the name tensor
flow with a whole bunch of typos that I
could totally conceive of um I don't
when when there's 600,000 downloads of
this a day I don't need to get too many
of these right because they're going to
actually hit there um tip goes out goes
oh I actually see a tensor Flow by that
name so I'm going to download that and
you've been exploited and so how do we
protect against this actually happening
in the real world well there this is a
tough one to mitigate against but one of
the things to beware again I as I said
before this is a higher risk on pii than
cran so don't don't go about being
terrified of everything this is not
about being scared but me the big
advantage in this is that many because
of the recent exploits and this
happening many in the python Community
are watching for these malicious
packages so they do not stay on PPI very
long and that's actually a good thing it
I mean most of these are found within a
matter of days if not less and so one of
one mitigation is just to avoid the
latest packages and updates from the
public repositories which sounds
counterintuitive but latest isn't always
the safest from a security standpoint so
one of the ways you can actually
leverage this in um package manager as
we've talked about before is repository
snapshots pin your installations to a
slightly older version and give that
time to get through a combination of
things like package blocking that we
talked about before give give yourself
time to let that be found and blocked
and you're you're only sacrificing a
little bit of latest and greatest
updates and you can always make an
exception if there is some really
important update you to a package that
you trust that you want to go
download but also just get it right and
you know avoid your
typos and the last one I want to talk
about is dependency confusion which is
probably one of the more sophisticated
uh uh ways of of handling this very
you'll notice it's very similar to typo
squatting let's start with our same
empty environment here this time we've
got our own internal packages say we
have my company does a lot of developer
of our own packages uh we we're here at
posit so we created this posit tools
package that we don't intend to publish
because it's just got internal code for
like connecting to our internal
databases and things like that but we're
going to uh so we have this internal
package it could be just somehow
installed somewhere it could be in our
internal we we could be sophisticated
enough to have our own internal
repository that we install from that's
pip likee or pii like along with that we
want to get some packages from pii of
course because we need to use pandas and
requests or something with it um we do a
pip install uh in this case more
commonly we probably have an extra index
URL rather than having our own um PPI
mirror um so we say in addition to the
the full pii I want to use our internal
server for additional packages and I
want to install posit
tools great we get posit tools it didn't
pip doesn't find it on the public
repository it goes oh I'll look at the
extra index oh we found it there so we
install it from there perfect this is a
happy way to work an encouraged way to
work with multiple packages there and
then I want pandas for example as well
it goes pit does the same thing I I
found it on PPI I'm not looking one
place only so we're
fine let's go back again this
time I my nefarious hat again here I'm
going to guess that a company like P it
has a posit tools package you could be a
GSK have assuming someone has a GSK
tools package I know it could be anyone
there's lots of or or heaven forbid you
have a package called internal tools or
something like that
uh and so I put a package on another
evil package I guess the name you might
use for an internal package I give it a
very high version number so it looks
newer than everything else and then same
thing I want to upgrade my posit tools
package or could be installing from
first first time pip goes out and goes
oh I you want to upgrade this one I see
a copy of this on pii it's got a newer
version than the one you have before I
even look for your internal one I'm
going to take your this one that I found
this nefarious one off Pipi and you've
been exploited again um so there are
solutions to this one I love because
this one is a very simple solution if
you have pu package manager so what's
one and it's use you know unified local
and private rep public repository here
so in package manager you can actually
take your internal packages combine them
with PPI packages in a single repository
say p put the preference on internal
packages first and then when I call PIP
install using my internal PPI mirror
that I have in package manager uh
install posit tools I will pip will
always will ask package manager who will
always give them back the internal
package no matter if anyone adds a new
package by the same name in Pipi later
on and so this completely insulates you
from any of this dependency confusion in
that
way um which is great um and same thing
if I'm doing pandas it goes package
manager knows it's not in the internal
source I'm going to look in the public
source and find what I need
here all that to be
said I know that some of this sounds a
little scary especially if you were
imagine if you were on the info security
side and going this is terrifying that
something like this some some simple
mistake like this and a fairly
unsophisticated attack like this could
cause problems within our internal
Network the takeaway is public packages
while they do present
risks don't you don't need to be scared
of them the understanding these risks
help give helps give you the knowledge
to manage them and there are strategies
and tools like package manager or others
even just understanding you know how
that works you can you can think of
other ways you could actually solve some
of these problems the same way to help
you reduce those risks and so you can
have those conversations with your
security teams and say hey
don't just say no let's at least turn
that no into a let's talk about what we
can do to make this better and that's
hopefully what you take away from it and
thank you so
much thank you Joe um we do have a
couple questions so are there any
scanners that you know of that do exist
for our code itself that look for any
malicious
intent actually scanning our code I
think so very very um uh no I mean very
very few most of the scanners out there
there are either commercial Solutions um
besides some common linters for R
they're just checking source code there
but as far as checking packages most of
those that you see listed out there as
so-called vulnerability scanners for R
are doing little more than exactly what
we're talking about here they're just
looking cataloging what package names
and versions you're using looking them
up in the vulnerability databases and um
frankly that's for the most part that's
what python is doing as well though
there can be a little 's a little bit
more out there for python
scanning I had one uh that I was
thinking of before and I was thinking if
we at posit do any like active curation
of the Python any kind of malicious
things out there and like pull them out
of pack man package managers currently
but but between you and me we're working
on
stuff than thanks for the trade
secret any other questions uh let's see
if there's any more in the side
so there's nothing in the slideer we do
have one more minute if anyone has any
questions you one over here you can just
try to be
loud it does not currently use the same
CBE type scoring that yeah I mean most
of the the stuff that's gone in there
has come
from can be linked to cves that do have
a scoring but the ACT there's not
actually a scoring implemented in that
osv database right
cool thank you thank you let's give Joe
one more round of
[Applause]
applause